بمعنى الان من موسكم مراسله الجزيره سلام
خضر هل هناك اي تصريح روسي بخصوص هذه
المعلومات التي وردتها وسائل الاعلام
هولنديه وتم تناولها من قبل وزراء خليجيه
عده دول
تعليق من قبل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على ما
تنقلته وسائل الاعلام حول سقوط صواريخ في
بولندا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقول ان
تصريحات المسؤولين الفنلنديين ووسائل
اعلام هولنديه حول سقوط صواريخ روسيه في
اراضي البولنديه يعتبروا تصعيدا خطيرا
وتحفيزا للموقف وقالت وزاره الدفاع ان
الحطام الذي تم نشر صوره همم داخل الاراضي
الفنلنديه ليس له اي علاقه باي همم اسلحه
روسيه تم تدميرها بمعنى ان وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه الان تنفي بشكل قاطع
سقوط اي صواريخ روسيه داخل الاراضي
الفنديه وتؤكد ان الصور التي تم تداولها
لما قيل انه حطام الصاروخين اللذين سقطاه
داخل الاراضي البولنديه ليسان من ضمن
منظومه التسريح الروسيه التي يستخدمها
الجيش الروسي تنعام او حتى الجيش الروسي
العامل همم في اوكرانيا على عده جبهات هذا
بحسب وزاره الدفاع فقط نشير مياده الا انه
هذا هو اول رد فعل من الجانب الروسي على
هذه المعلومات المتداوله واللافته ان الرد
اتى من وزاره الدفاع اذن وفق وزاره الدفاع
هناك نفي روسي ولكن نذكر سلام
كل التصريحات المتعلقه بان يكون هناك اي
خروج همم ما يتعلق بنطاق هذه الحرب عن
حدود اوكرانيا تصريحات روسيه بطبيعه الحال
بالضبط اليوم كان هناك
مجلس الامن القومي
الولايات المتحده بانها تقوم بالتلاعب
بالدول والتعبير
وقال ان واشنطن تدفع العالم باتجاه حرب
عالميه ثالثه الجانب الروسي وخاصه في
اليومين الماضيين كان يؤكد ويقول بان
موسكو على استعداد للعوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات مع
لكن العائق الاساسي والعائق الكبير
بالنسبه
القرار السياسي حول العوده الى طاوله
المفاوضات من عدمها لم يعد بيد القياده
السياسيه الاوكرانيه بالنسبه لموسكو موسكو
تقوم بان من يتخذ قرارات كهذه هو الجانب
الامريكي بشكل كبير وهناك ايضا تصريحات
كانت تتحدث عن ان موسكو تتعرض هجمه كبيره
ليس فقط من قبل همم اوكرانيا ميدانيا بل
اوكرانيا مدعومه
بمنظومه تسلح كبيره سواء من الولايات
المتحده او من باقي دول النيت واليوم ايضا
كان هناك رد فعل من وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه حول ما اعلنه حلف شمال الاطلسي عن
انه سيبدا بتدريب وحدات من الجيش
الاوكراني الجانب الروسيه اعتبر هذا موقفا
حادا وغير ودود من قبل همم حلف شمال
الاطلسي بمعنى ان التصريحات الروسيه تؤكد
مرارا وتكرارا انها مستعده للتفاوض ولكن
تلقي بالله على الجانب الاخر وهناك
اتهامات دوما توجه خاصه الى الولايات
المتحده بانها من تقوم بتصعيد الموقف